شكرا لك رشا اهلا بكم مشاهدينا الكرام في
هذه الساعه الجديده ضمن تغطيه العربيه
المستمره لزلزال تركيا وسوريا يتضائل
الامل في العثور على ناجينا في سوريا
وتركيا بعد مرور سته ايام على الزلزال
المدمر الذي اودى بحياه اكثر من 27 الف
شخص في احدى اسوا الكوارث التي تشهدها هذه
المنطقه منذ قرن واعلن رئيس تركيا رجب طيب
اردوغان ارتفاع عدد قتل الزلزال المدمر في
تركيا الى
21,848 قتيلا وعدد المصابين الى ثمانين
الف ومائه واربعه يذكر ان ارقام الضحايا
تتغير على نحو مضطرد على مدار الساعه هذا
في تركيا اما في سوريا فارتفع عدد القتلى
في عموم البلاد الى اكثر من 5000 قتيل
واعلنت منظمه الدفاع المدني السوريه
المعروفه باسم الخوذ البيضاء
اللامؤشرات على وجود احياء تحت الانقاض
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
اذا مشاهدينا الكرام نتابع معكم هذه الصور
التي وصلتنا من جنديرس في شمال سوريا وهي
احدى المناطق الاكثر تضررا جراء هذا
الزلزال الذي ضرب المنطقه الحدوديه للضربه
ولايه كهرمان مرعش في سوريا وامتدت في
تركيا وامتدت اثاره الى مناطق عده في شمال
غرب سوريا شاهدوا حجم الدمار الذي رصدته
هذه
الكاميرا الطائره ايضا من هذه الطائره
المسيره التي تصور حجم الدمار في جنديرس
طبعا كانت هناك انتقادات لعدم وصول فرق
اغاثه كافيه الى هذه المنطقه لانتشال طبعا
الناجين من تحت الركام
وطبعا كان هناك
حديث على طبعا جهود منفرده من قبل الخوض
البيضاء هناك لانقاذ الناس طبعا اكوام
الركام كما تتابعون تظهر بشكل كبير اذا
كما تابعنا في هذه الصور الصور من جنديرس
في حلب وبعد بالعوده الى تركيا ايضا وبعد
مرور نحو 133 ساعه على الزلزال المدمر
الذي ضرب تركيا تمكنت فرق الانقاذ من
انتشال طفل عمره عامان ورغم مرور سته ايام
على الزلزال الذي بلغت شدته 7.7 درجه تم
انتشل الطفل علي داغلي من تحت انقاض مبنى
منهار بولايتها تاي وفق وكاله الاناضول
التركيه في وقت تتضاعل فيه فرص العثور على
نجينا من الزلزال الذي ضرب تركيا وسوريا
الاثنين الماضي وحصد ارواح الالاف حيث
يخوض رجال الانقاذ سباقا مع الزمن لانتشال
العالقين وسط سوء الاحوال الجويه
تمكنت فرق الانقاذ في مدينه كرمان مرعش من
انقاذ طفل من تحت الانقاض بعد مرور ايام
على بقائه عالقا اسفل حطام المبنى
[موسيقى]
ان شاء الله
الحمد لله الحمد لله رب العالمين الحمد
لله
وحده تسع سنين
الله يسلمك
[موسيقى]
انت ترى اكثر اكثر مني انا لا استطيع
مشاهده
نعم الان نايف الان نايف كما تشاهد الان
نايف كما تشاهد يتم نعم الان كما تشاهد
نايف
نعم نايف نعم
نعم نايف لكن طلبوا منا ان نصمت يعني لكن
عائشه عائشه الان نايف الحمد لله عائشه
خرجت من فم الموت
عائشه الان تخرج بعد ولاده عسيره وولاده
قيصريه نايف عيشه تخرج من رحم الركام نايف
لا ادري ان كنت تسمعني انقطع الاتصال لا
ادري ان كنت تسمعني
لا ادري كيف كنت تسمعني انقطع الاتصال ان
كنتم
الان يعني يحاولون تثبيت
الان يثبتون الان يثبتون الان الان نايف
الان نايف بسرعه بسرعه
الان نايف نايف ان كنت تسمعني ان كنت
تسمعني ان كنت تسمعني
ان كنت تسمعني الان نايف على اكتف نعم على
اكتف نعم عائشه على اكتف المسعفين باتجاه
الاسعاف عائشه عائشه يا نايف عائشه تخرج
من رحم الركام عائشه تعود للحياه عائشه
تخرج من فم الموت نايف عائشه بعد ولادها
قيصريه بعد ولاده عسيره عائشه الان الى
الاسعاف الان تصل الاسعاف نايف
وتحمل الان بالاسعاف تحمل بالاسعاف الان
لحظه
[موسيقى]
وسط كل هذا اوقفت الشرطه التركيه مشاهدينا
نحو اثني عشر مقاولا بعد انهيار الاف
المباني جنوب شرق البلاد جراء الزلزال
وتاتي هذه الاعتقالات على خلفيه شبهات
بوجود ثغرات في عمليات البناء تسببت في
انهيار سريع وسهل لبعض المباني ويتوقع
توقيف مزيد من الاشخاص بعد اصدار المدعي
العام في ديار بكر احدى المحافظات العشر
المتضرره بالزلزال 29 مذكره توقيف في حق
مقاولين في مجال البناء
نعود الى عمليات الانقاذ وثقت كاميرا
العربيه لحظه انقاذ شخص من اسفل حطام مبنى
ضربه زلزال المدمر في غازي عنتاب نشاهد
[موسيقى]
صور تذكاريه وكرسي لطفل صغير هو اخر ما
تبقى في هذا المنزل الذي دمر بشكل كبير في
مدينه اصلاحيه بولايه غاز عنتاب التقديرات
الاوليه تشير الى ان نصف المباني في هذه
المدينه قد دمرت بالكامل اضافه لعشرات
المباني غير الصالحه للسكن على سبيل
المثال هذا الحي قد دمر بالكامل ولم يبقى
في المنتصف سوى هذا المبنى المتداعي والذي
ستقوم السلطات التركيه بهدنه بعد الانتهاء
من عمليه ازاله الانقار الحكومه التركيه
تقول ان حجم الدمار انتشر على مسافه
تقريبا 500 كيلو متر في الولايات العشر
المنكوبه زيدان زنجلو من مدينه اصلاحيه
غازي عنتاب
الامل في كهرمان مراش لم ينسحب على جميع
ما ينتظر خبرا من تحت الركام عن احبائه
فقد اظهر مقطع فيديو متداول ابا تركيا وهو
يصرخ باسماء افراد عائلته املا في اي
اشاره على بقائهم احياء تحت الانقاض
[موسيقى]
تمكنت فرق البحث والانقاذ في هاتايا
التركيه من العثور على طفل عالق تحت
الانقاض بعد مرور 128 ساعه
ونتابع في منها طاي في جنوب تركيا
معنا نحن في اليوم السادس بعد
الزلزال صور مباشره يبدو ان فريق الانقاذ
عندك لم يفقد الامل رغم كل هذه المده وما
يزال هناك امل في العثور على ناجين
صحيح
صحيح لهم يعني تخيل لهم من ساعات من اكثر
تقريبا من خمس ساعات نحن نواكب هذه
العمليه هي معقده للغايه جدا صهيب وهم لم
يفقدوا الامل وكل تقريبا ساعه يقومون
باجراء فحص جديد ما اذا كانت هذه السيده
تحت الانقاض على لا تزال على قيد الحياه
اخر فحص لديهم قبل قليل اثبت انها لا تزال
على قيد الحياه رغم الاستجابه البطيئه لهم
لم يفقدوا الامل
هنالك جهاز يستخدمونه يعني هم طبعا حفروا
باتجاهين من السقف ومن اسفل السقف ايضا
للوصول الى هذه السيده هنالك جهاز يقرا
الانفاس والحركات واستجابه الشخص الذي على
قيد الحياه هم يخاطبونها بمعنى يطلب منها
ان تتحرك بطريقه معينه او تضرب بطريقه
معينه في حال انها على قيد الحياه
واستجابت لهم قبل قليل يعني هذا الامر
الذي يمنعهم عن التخلي او التوقف رغم ان
المده الزمنيه طالت وان التحدي كبير جدا
وانا العقبات امامهم كبيره جدا يعني نحن
نقف هنا نشاهد يعني نشعر فعلا بالتعب
والارهاق الذي هم يواجههم والصعوبه التي
تواجههم ولكن تخيل يعني هذا المشهد يختزل
امر معين صهيب اذا كنا نحن تعبنا من
الانتظار
وتعبنا من هذا المشهد ومن وهم تعبوا من
العمل ما بالك في الشخص الذي ينتظر ان
يصلوا اليه وله سته ايام تحت الانقاذ
وبالتالي اي شخص مكانهم لن يتوقف لن يياس
يعني سيستمر في العمل الى ان يعني يبذل
قصار جهده للوصول الى هذه الحاله وهي على
فكره سيده كما تحدثنا من قبل واستجابت لهم
وهي مدركه لما يعني يتحدثون به نتمنى ان
يتمكن الفريق لانقاذ هذا من اخراجها نعم
من تحت هذا الركام طبعا يعني هناك قصص
يعني رائعه
تشبث الانسان بالرغبه في البقاء رغبه طول
هذه المده ولكن حدثني عمار يعني غير هذا
الموقع
طبعا فيها تاي ما الذي تمكنت من رصده فيما
يتعلق
باستمرار الجهود الان او متى سيكون هناك
فقدان للامل او الانتقال الى مرحله اخرى
بالنظر الى المده
الطويله الان بعد بعد الزلزال ام ستستمر
هذه الفرق للبحث يعني مهما مهما كلف الامر
او مهما طال الوقت
هو السؤال الذي يخشى الجميع ان يسالوا
ويخشى الاجابه انه هل ستعلن السلطات
التركيه او وقف البحث عن الاحياء تحت
الانقاض هذا السؤال المهم والاكبر لانه
على غرار سوريا مثلا او المدن التي ضربت
في سوريا انا لا اعتقد ذلك لكن يعني هنالك
بما ان اليوم خرجت حالات كثيره من تحتها
الانقاض واخرها في هاتاي وكانت طفله
مرعش هنالك امل يعني كلما تجدد كلما كانت
هنالك حالات تخرج من تحت الانقاذ وبالتالي
من يستطيع من الذي يستطيع ان يحكم
بالاعدام على شخص يوقف هذه العمليات فانا
كانما حكم عليه بالاعدام لانه لا يعرف
يعني الانفاس متى تتوقف وبالتالي هذه
العمليات اعتقد انها مستمره رغم ان
الصعوبات كبيره جدا وخصوصا هنا في هاتاي
لان لان الدمار هائل صهيب منذ الصباح احنا
من صباح الباكر ده احنا نرصد حالات وجبنا
في يعني في مختلف المناطق والاحياء
السكنيه هنالك حالات طبعا محزنه جدا لاناس
يعني لديهم اطفال تحت الانقاض ولكن يصعب
العمل لان البنايه ربما تنهدم في حال
عملوا عليها وكانوا بصدد يعني
ايجاد طريقه واليه معينه للعثور عليهم
واخراجهم بدون ان تنهار البنايه على رؤوس
عمال الانقاذ كما حدث ايضا في انطاكيا هنا
في هاتايا الفيديو الذي انتشر اليوميه
تنهار على عمال الانقاذ يعني العمليه صعبه
للغايه ومعقده ان الغايه وليست وليست
بسيطه هنالك طبعا حالات لاشخاص نعم نعم
هنالك حالات لاشخاص وعائلات لا تزال تحت
الانقاض ومن يراقب من من اقاربهم لا يريد
سوى يعني الحصول على جثمينهم لدفنها القصص
كثيره ومحزنه
ومرعبه للغايه وانت احيانا يعني صراحه
صهيب تشتم رائحه الموت والجثث في اماكن
معينه نعم عند هذه الرائحه طبعا رائحه
الموت كما وصفتها عمار يعني اسالك هل هناك
اي توقعات يعني للحصيله الان عند 27 الف
قتيل وهو رقم كبير جدا في كل من تركيا
وسوريا صحيح ولكن يبقى رقما مهولا يعني
والرقم الاكبر في في تركيا هل هناك اي
توقعات
بالعدد الذي يمكن ان تصل اليه اعداد
الضحايا جراء هذا الزلزال عمار
للاسف الشديد للاسف الشديد للاسف الشديد
عداد الموتى في هذه الكارثه ربما يرتفع
لان المباني كثيره ولا يزال تحتها اعداد
تزال اعداد كبيره تحت الانقاض ولا يمكن
حصر اعداد المفقودين تحت الارقام فطالما
ان الركام لم يرفع عن كل المباني المدمره
فاحنا نحن في احتمال ان يزداد هذا العدد
وهناك طبعا تحذيرات بان توقعات بان يصل
الى 40 الف قتيل ولكن السؤال الاكبر كم
عدد الذين تبقوا تحت الانقاض حتى هذه
اللحظه ومتى سينتهي ومتى سيستطيع فعلا ان
ينجزوا هذا العمل الكبير الصعب المضني نعم
صهيب شكرا جزيلا لك اذا في انتظار اي خبر
صار من الموقع الذي انت فيه عمار الهندي
من هاتاي
ومع مرور اليوم السادس منذ وقوع الزلزال
في تركيا وسوريا ورغم تراجع الامل بالعثور
على المزيد من الناجين الا ان فرق البحث
لا تزال تنقذ العديد من الضحايا كما نتابع
او تابعنا معكم قبل قليل اخرهم سيدتان
قضتا اكثر من
222 ساعه تحت الانقاض
[موسيقى]
رين بعض
وخلال عمل عناصر لفرق الانقاذ فيها طاي
انهارت الانقاض عليهم اثناء محاولات
انتشار احياء من تحت الركام شاهدوا
[موسيقى]
هذا هو لا يزال اهالي الضحايا العالقين
تحت لانقاذ جراء الزلزله في تركيا يرافقون
فرق الانقاذ والبحث لتلقي اي اخبار عن
ذويهم رغم المؤشرات بعدم وجودنا
كان يعيش اخي وخالتي بعد انهيار البناء
قفزوا من النافله لا اعلم ان كان علي
الفرح لانهم القوا بانفسهم ونجوا او احزن
على من فقدوا ارواحهم هناك
[موسيقى]
لعل هناك امل لكن على ما يبدو الامل
يتضاءل
اقرب حسبما نعلم ان هناك 60 شخصا تحت ركام
هذا المبنى فقدوا ارواحهم والان 14 شخصا
تحت الانقاض ما زالوا هناك حتى هذه اللحظه
من بينهم اقاربي
[موسيقى]
في بدايه الزلزال انهار المبنى وقيل لنا
لا يوجد مؤشر على وجود ناجين لكن بقينا
ننتظر
ومشاهد اخرى هي
مشاهد فيديو وتظهر عشرات القبور التي تم
حفرها في غازي عنتاب في تركيا لضحايا
زلزال المدمر الذي اودى بحياه الالاف
نتابع
[موسيقى]
واظهرت صور جويه من مدينه هاتايا التركيه
مقابر جماعيه لمئات من ضحايا زلزال المدمر
[موسيقى]
هذا هو تضررت الكنيسه الرومانيه
الكاثوليكيه التي يبلغ عمرها نحو 152 عاما
بشكل كبير جراء الزلزال الذي ضرب الاراضي
التركيه
اعاده زلزال كهرمان مرعش الحديث عن مدى
التزام البلديات والمقاولين في تركيا
بقوانين ولوائح البناء التي اقرت في عام
99 بعد زلزال ازميت وانتقد خبراء ضعف
البناء والذي تسبب في انهيار بعض المباني
بشكل كارثي
الزمان اغسطس
1999 المكان ولايه ازميت بتركيا الحدث
زلزال بقوه سبع درجات فاصله سته على مقياس
ريختر هز البلاد 45 ثانيه خلفت اكثر من 17
الف قابيل وما يقدر بنحو 500 الف شخص
اجراءات كثيره اتخذت لتفادي تكرار الكابوس
في بلد اراد قدره الجغرافي ان يكون بلد
الزلازل قوانين ولوائح بناء جديده ابرزها
فرض تحديث البنيه التحتيه لتكون اكثر
مقاومه للزلازل وفرض ضريبه الزلزال
للاستعداد للاسوء لكن اليوم وبعدما تكرر
السيناريو اصوات تتساءل عن اموال ضريبه
الزلازل وفيما استثمرت ينتقدون عفوا عن
البناء غير القانوني مقابل دفع غرامه
محدده قدمته الحكومه التركيه
اتهامات بالمقابل تطالب البلديات
والمقاولين بالاهمال القاتل السلطات لاحقت
واعتقلت العشرات من المقاولين بعد الزلزال
ومنعت اخرين من السفر للتحقيق معهم
والى سوريا الان حيث اظهرت صور لعمليه
انقاذ فتاه سوريه تبلغ من العمر 16 عاما
من تحت الانقاض اذا هي فتاه سوريه ولكن في
مدينه كهرمان مرعش التركيه نتابع
[موسيقى]
وفي داخل سوريا وصفه بغير مسبوق طوال عمره
واخرى تسبب لها هول الزلزال بصعوبات
مستمره في النوم انهم ضحايا الزلزال
المدمر في سوريا الذين يصفون ما شاهدوه من
رعب لازمهم حتى اليوم نتابع
اول مره بتصير هيك بهالفجعه هيك بهاللي
انا بعيشها 52 سنه ما مر علي هيك والله اي
حركه عم نحس دائما
بالبيت يعني
فاضطريت الج على الجامع ادوات اللجنه
وفي الوقت الذي تستمر فيه عمليات البحث عن
احياء تحت الركام
وجراء الزلزال الذي ضرب سوريا وتركيا يعيش
السوريون في الخارج لحظات عصيبه بانتظار
معرفه مصيري اقربائهم الزميله زينه عادي
زارت منزله عائلتي شاب سوري مقيما في
فرنسا خسر مجموعه من اقربائه في مدينه
جنديرس السوريه جراء الزلزال نتابع
هذه العائله السوريه يخيم الحزن على
الجميع بعدما قضى بعض اقربائهم تحت
الانقاض وتشرد اخرون في العراء
[موسيقى]
بفتح الواتساب احد يعني احد الشباب ناشر
انه فلان اللي هو ابن عمي توفى هو وابنه
بتختي ساكنين جنبه يعني فتواصلت مع احد
الشباب اللي بيشتغلوا بالدفاع المدني كان
عنده انترنت
فخبرني انه في اختك وفي زوجه وفي جزء من
اطفالها توفوا وايضا ابن عمي الثاني كمان
بنت وتوفت لحد الان ما في ما في احصائيه
دقيقه انه كم شخص سواء انا خسرت او اي
انسان حتى موجود بسوريا او موجود بتركيا
لحد الان يعني بالمناطق اللي تضررت الناس
ماني عارفه شو خسرت هذا اخي احمد
زلزال الاولى ترك عيلته وراح لعند موقع
الحدث بنلاحظ انه عم بيطلعوا طفل عايش
[موسيقى]
تحت الركام وعم نحاول بالامكانات
المعابر والحدوديه بين تركيا وسوريا هي
طوق النجاه الاخير للناجين من هول الزلزال
المدمر في شمال غرب سوريا نتعرف معا على
ابرز هذه المعابر الحدوديه
[موسيقى]
بحبل نجاه اخير يتمثل بفتح المعابر
الحدوديه مع تركيا كي تعود الحياه شبه
طبيعيه بعد زلزال قضى على البشر والحجر
لكن ما هي اهم المعابر الحدوديه بين سوريا
وتركيا وايها يعمل ليكون شريان حياه لاكثر
من اربعه ملايين شخص في شمال سوريا
معبر باب الهوى هو حاليا المعبر الرسمي
الوحيد في شمال ادلب لعبور المساعدات
الانسانيه الى سوريا بموجب قرار مجلس
الامن الدولي تسيطر عليه المعارضه السوريه
معبر باب السلامه في منطقه اعزاز شمال حلب
تسيطر عليه فصائل المعارضه السوريه معبر
جرابلس في ريف حلب تسيطر عليه فصائل
المعارضه السوريه ايضا
دوليا المنظمات الامميه طالبت النظام
السوري بتسهيل مرور المساعدات الى مناطق
المعارضه من دون قيد او شرط اما مجلس
الامن فسيعقد الاسبوع المقبل جلسه لمناقشه
امكانيه السماح للامم المتحده بارسال
مساعدات الى شمال غرب سوريا عبر اكثر من
معبر حدودي
بدوره النظام السوري اعلن موافقته على
ايصال مساعدات للمناطق المتضرره الخارجه
عن سيطرته
واستردد تركي بعد ان قالت انقره انها تدرس
قرارها محاسن حضاره العربيه
رجح نائب للامين العام للامم المتحده
للشؤون الانسانيه ان يتجاوز عدد ضحايا
الزلزال في تركيا وسوريا الاربعين الف
قتيل وقال جريفيث خلال مقابله صحفيه انه
من الصعب للغايه اعطاء تقدير دقيق لان
الانقاض لم يتم ازالتها بعد لكنه يعتقد ان
عدد القتل سيتضاعف او يزيد مع تواصل
عمليات ازاحه الركام والدمار
من جانبها قالت منظمه الصحه العالميه ان
الزلزال الذي ضرب الاراضي التركيه
والسوريه تسبب بضرر طال سته وعشرين مليون
شخص من بينهم مليون واربعمائه الف طفل
تاثروا بشده بسبب الزلزال اضافه الى 350
الف مسن فيما اصبح اكثر من خمسه ملايين
شخص في خطر داهم وحضرت الصحه العالميه من
تضرر عشرات المستشفيات مع ارتفاع عدد
القتلى من الزلزال الى اكثر من 27 الفا
كما اطلقت المنظمه نداء عاجلا طلبت فيه
42,8 مليون دولار لمساعدتها على تلبيه
الاحتياجات الصحيه العاجله
معنا من بيروت دكتوره سلوى ابو شقره مديره
المكتب الاعلاميه الاقليمي لمنظمه اطباء
بلا حدود مرحبا بك معنا دكتوره سلوى في
هذه الساعه من العربيه كيف استجابت
وتستجيب اطباء بلا حدود مع هذا الزلزال
المدمر في كل من تركيا وسوريا
مساء الخير تعمل اطباء بلا حدود منذ
اللحظات الاولى لهذه الكارثه في شمال غرب
سوريا طبعا كما تعلمون كما خسر كثر
احبائهم اقربائهم اثنين من زملائنا
العاملين في شمال غرب سوريا وكثير من
كم وايضا ولكنهم يعملون بشكل كبير وبجهد
كبير لتامين الاحتياجات الطبيه والانسانيه
لكل الاشخاص المتضررين على الارض منذ
ساعات الاولى طبعا تم تقييم هذه
الاحتياجات ولكن يعلم ان سوريا تعاني اكثر
من عشره اعوام من حرب وتبعتها ازمه
اقتصاديه وكذلك
في هذا البلد نعم طيب الدكتوره سلوى كان
هناك لون وعتاب من جانب
المناطق السوريه خاصه المناطق السوريه
التابعه للمعارضه السوريه في شمال غرب
سوريا بانهم تركوا وحيدين يعني
امام هذه الكارثه ما قولكم في هذا وهل
قدمت منظمتكم او اي منظمات اخرى مساعدات
للمناطق الخاضعه لسيطره المعارضه في سوريا
منظمه بلا حدود تعمل في شمال غرب سوريا
كما في شمال شرق سوريا منذ عشر سنه يقولون
انه صوتك يعني رديء نوعا ما هلا قربتي
المايك يعني نعم
اين منظمه اطباء
منظمه اطباء بلا حدود موجوده منذ اكثر من
عشر سنوات في شمال غرب سوريا وشمال شرق
سوريا تواقمنا التي تعمل هناك اكثر من 400
شخص موجودون على الارض وهم يقدمون الدعم
الطبي والانساني ولم نحن موجودين على
الارض
الرعايه الطبيه نعم هل من احصاءات يعني هل
لديكم اي ارقام بالنسبه لاعداد الضحايا
اعداد المباني المدمره يعني ما الذي رصدته
منظمه اطباء بلا حدود في سوريا خصوصا
دكتوره سلوى
ولكن في الايام الاولى وصل اكثر من 4000
شريح الى العيادات التي نعمل فيها
والمستشفيات التي ندعمها واكثر من فئه 600
شخص فقدوا حياتهم ايضا وصلوا الى مستشفىنا
وطبعا هذه الارقام هي في ازدياد بمرور
الساعات والايام
نعم طيب
ذكرت انه لديكم اربع مئه شخص من اطباء بلا
حدود في شمال غرب سوريا هل يعني تعملون
ايضا في المناطق الخاضعه لسيطره النظام
اطباء بلا حدود كانت تطلب منذ سنوات بين
السلطات المحليه ان تعمل في هذه المناطق
والى اليوم
اي اجابه بامكانيه ولكن نحن نرغب بان نكون
موجودين لتقديم الدعم الطبي والانساني نعم
طيب الدكتوره سلوى كذلك فيما يتعلق
الضحايا هناك الالاف من الضحايا الان في
في سوريا جراء هذا الزلزال يعني هل
اعطيتنا المزيد من المعطيات حول التكفل
بذوي هؤلاء الضحايا بالناجين كذلك كيف يتم
هل هناك اي ارقام متعلقه باعداد من تضرروا
جراء هذا الزلزال وكيف يتم ايواءهم وتقديم
المساعده لهم الان اذا كانت
الارقام ولكن تم انشاء خيام بمقابل
المستشفيات ومراكز الطبيه التي ندعمها
ولكن اريد التجديد ايضا ان الان تركيزنا
ينصب على الدعم الاغاثي الفوري ولكن يجب
ان ناخذ عن الاعتبار اطاله امد هذه الازمه
لاننا لا زلنا نحصي المناطق المتضرره
وكيفيه الاستجابه ايضا جراء هذا الزلزال
وتبعته ولك هناك اثار ثانويه لهذا الزلزال
الذي اريد ان اشدد عليها اذ تعاني المنطقه
نقص في الكهرباء هناك تخوف من تفشي او
الامراض وحاليا بدا ايضا مخزوننا الاولي
بالنفاذ ولذلك نسعى الى انتظار
المساعدات ايضا على ذكر المساعدات
الدكتوره سلوى كان هناك يعني رفع جزئي
للعقوبات المفروضه على الحكومه السوريه في
دمشقها وعلى النظام السوري من قبل المجتمع
الدولي في سبيل ايصال المساعدات الى
المناطق المنكوبه جراء الزلزال ووفقه
وكاله الانباء السوريه سانا فان حكومه
دمشق تعهدت بايصال المساعدات حتى للمناطق
غير الخاضعه لسيطرتها هل رصدتم وصول اي
مساعدات من جانب القوات النظاميه السوريه
او من الحكومه السوريه في دمشق الى الى
هاته المناطق
فالوقت الحالي لازلنا نترق
ب لم
نطلع وصول هذه ولكن لنقول ان المعابر
الحدوديه يجب ان تبقى متاحه لتلبيه بعض
الاحتياجات العاجله للاشخاص المتضررين على
نعم دعيني اعود الى المستشفيات دكتوره
سلوى مدام اطباء بلا حدود تعمل منذ فتره
في في مناطق الشمال السوري
كيف تقيمين الان وضع المستشفيات التي
تعملون فيها والخدمات الطبيه الموجوده
هناك ويعني اي معطيات متعلقه بهذه الخدمات
الان جراء هذه الكارثه الان جراء الزلزال
نحن في الوقت الحالي نعمل في اكثر من سبعه
مستشفيات من بين ايضا وحدات لمعالجه
الحروق و12 مركز يقدم الرعايه الصحيه
الاوليه
وكذلك قمنا بتوزيع اكثر من 2500 مواد مثل
البطانيات وغيرها احتياجات الاشخاص على
الارض وتم لا مركزي امومه ولذلك نتكلم
الدكتوره سلوى اين عذرا على المقاطعه
في مناطق مختلفه في ادلب وحلب باريس
بمناطق مختلفه في شمال غرب هل هذه
المستشفيات الان تعمل يعني تقدم خدمات
كبيره للمتضررين شراء الزلزال تفضلي صحيح
انا اتقدم بخدمات طبيه وكذلك هناك دعم
نفسي للاشخاص المتضررين على الارض ولكن
تعمل منظر لحظات الاولى للزلزال على تقديم
الرعايه الطبيه والانسانيه لكل المتضررين
جراء هذه الكارثه نعم طيب ذكرتي انه تمت
اقامه مجموعه من الخيام حوالي حول هذه
المستشفيات
يعني هل لديكم اعداد كم اعداد هذه الخيم
او اعداد الاشخاص الذين تم ايوائهم بعد
الزلزال
هم مجموعه من الاشخاص المتضررين ليست لدي
الان الارقام النهائيه لان الارقام
بازدياد ولكن من بين الاشخاص المتدارين في
المنطقه وايضا زملائنا الذين خسروا بيوتهم
وخسروا اقاربهم ايضا لم يعد لديهم اي ملجا
ليكون
وا موجود يعني حتى من اطباء بلا حدودهم
متضررون طبعا من هذا الزلزال طيب دكتور
سلوى كلمه اخيره في هذه المقابله ذكرتها
انه المساعدات بدات تنفد او يعني
المستلزمات الخاصه
بالعاملين هناك من لدى اطباء بلا حدود الى
من توجهون كلمه عبر العربيه الان وماذا
تطلبون
يجب ان ترقى الجهود الدوليه
الى مفتوحه
طبيه للاطفال المتضررين لاننا نتكلم عن
كارثه قد تمتد لسنوات خصوصا ان البلد
وشمال غرب سوريا والمناطق كانت تعاني من
صعوبات طيله هذه العشر سنوات والان انا
اعتقد
ستخف حدتها بل ستزيد ايضا وسنتكلم عن
رعايه طبيه سنويه قد يحتاجها الاشخاص في
السنوات
طيب ما نوع الحاجات الاساسيه التي
تحتاجونها الان في المناطق السوريه
بالتحديد دكتوره سلوى
يتم تقييم من قبل فرقنا على الارض
الاحتياجات الطبيه التي تحتاجها
والاشخاص الموجودين على الارض ولكن هناك
احتياجات في مواد ايضا غير غذائيه نقوم
بتوزيعها ليس فقط مواد طبيه قدراتنا ايضا
الخاصه بالطوارئ ونجري محادثات مع سلطات
وشركاء المحليين في خلال البلدين لتقديم
الدعم شكرا جزيلا لك دكتوره سلوى ابو شقره
انت مديره المكتب الاعلاميه الاقليميه
لمنظمه اطباء بلا حدود
هذا ونظمه مجموعه من الناشطين والمدنيين
السوريين وقفه احتجاجيه في شمال سوريا
للتنديد بطاعات الامم المتحده مع الكارثه
الانسانيه التي تسبب بها الزلزال الذي ضرب
جنوب تركيا وشمال سوريا ويتهم السوريون في
المنطقه المنكوبه الامم المتحده يتهمونها
بالتقاعس في مد يد العون لهم حيث لم يسجل
دخول اي مساعدات لانقاذ وانتشال العالقين
تحت الانقاض خلال الايام الاولى من
الزلزال او حتى مساعدات انسانيه لمساعده
منكوبي المنطقه
[تصفيق]
وخلال عمليات الانقاذ تم تداوله العديد من
الصور المؤثره لناجين من الزلزال ومن
بينها سوره الطفله التي كانت تحمي راس
اخيها من الركام الشقيقان كتب لهما عمر
جديد لكنهما انضم الى المئات من الايتام
الذين خلفهم السلسال نتابع
عمليه الانقاذ وثقت للحظات مؤ
ثره مشاهد الطفله التي حمت راس اخيها حظيت
بتعاطف كبير
الطفلان الشقيقان ناجيان من الكارثه
لكنهما انضم الى الاف الايتام الذين خلفهم
الزلزاله جنان تبلغ خمس سنوات فيما لم
يتجاوز عمره شقيقها عبده 11 شهرا اصيب
كلاهما بالعديد من الجروح
ظلام محاصرين تحت انقاذ منزلهما لمده
يومين
اقارب جنان احتفوا بها ونصبوها اميره
احد الاقارب تطوع للاعتناء بالشقيقين
الله شافانا يعني
تحت
خواطر حولهم ضل لنا عبده وجنان تحت رحمه
رب العالمين
اثبتت الدراسات ان للزلزال اثار النفسيه
كبيره حيث اكدت ان واحد من بين كل اربعه
ناجين يعاني من اضطراب ما بعد الصدمه
اثار الزلازل النفسيه لا تقل عن الجسديه
اضطراب ما بعد الصدمه واكتئاب شديد
واحد من كل اربعه ناجين عانى من اضطراب ما
بعد الصدمه
دراسه في 2016 على 76 الف شخص من ضحايا
زلازل مختلفه
كيف يتم التعامل مع الحاله النفسيه اشعار
الناجين بالراحه التامه السؤال عن احوالهم
بشكل مستمر
مرحله التعافي المرحله الاولى هي الاكثر
صعوبه
يتخللها دعم نفسي واجتماعي المرحله
الثانيه الاهتمام بسلوكيات الناجي من
الزلازل
ومشاهد لاهالي تهدمت منازلهم بشكل كامل
واخرون فروا منها نتيجه تصدعها في حلب
جراء زلزال الذي ضرب جنوب تركيا وشمال
سوريا الاثنين الماضي
[موسيقى]
[ضحك]
وصل فريق انقاذ ايطالي الى العاصمه
اللبنانيه بيروت في طريقه لمناطق سيطره
النظام السوري للاغاثه من الزلزال ويعد
الفريق الايطالي اول فريق اوروبي للاغاثه
يرسل الى المناطق المتضرره في سوريا
للمساعده في عمليات الانقاذ
كاميرا العربيه قابلت مواطنا سوريا نجا من
تحت الانقاض في مدينه غازي عنتاب التركيه
حيث استخدم هاتفه المحمول للاتصال
باصدقائه الذين وصلوا وقاموا بحفر فتحه في
جدار منزله واخراجه
تقريبا نحن معصورين الله لمع الهاتف ضوء
الهاتف عرفت وين هو بين القزاز وبين جنب
منه حاولت اتصلت في واحد جمع رفقته
رفقاتنا جاء بعد ساعتين ونصف
فتحه هاي ما بتدخل ولد صغير عمره شغل بس
الله النعمه يعني وصلنا للموت والله عمر
ان ميت في هذه الدنيا
هذا واثبتت الاحداث التي حصلت في اعقب هذا
الزلزال المدمر منذ ايام ان اجهزه الهواتف
الذكيه لعبت دورا اساسيا في انقاذ عدد
كبير من الاشخاص المزيد في التقرير التالي
منتظرينا ومتشبثين باي فرصه تنقذهم من موت
وشيك فرصه وجدها هؤلاء تحت انقاذ الزلزال
عبر اجهزه الهواتف الذكيه وخاصيه البث
المباشر على مواقع التواصل التي لعبت دورا
اساسيا في انقاذ عدد كبير من العالقين تحت
المباني المدمره
اطلقها العليقون تحت الانقاض بتوثيق ما قد
يكون اخر ظهور لهم واخر لحظه عاشوها عبر
هواتفهم طلبا للنجده ونقل واقعهم
ومعاناتهم للعالم اجمع اثبتت القوه الخفيه
للتكنولوجيا فعاليتها في انقاذ الحياه في
ادق واصعب الظروف والكوارث الطبيعيه
امثله كثيره لناجين من انقاذ الزلزال لعل
ابرزها هذا الرجل الستيني علقه تحت
الانقاذ لقرابه 103 ساعات
ساهم في مساعده فرق الانقاذ للتوصل لمكانه
بعد ان تواصل مع عائلته بواسطه هاتفه
الحمد لله طلعت عايش انا عايش بهذه الجمله
بات الشاب السوري مثالا اخر على قوه
الهواتف الذكيه بالانقاذ بعد ان صور مقطع
فيديو من تحت الانقاب مستغيثا باي فرصه
نجاه هؤلاء هم جزء من كثيرين كتبت لهم
حياه جديده بعد ان تمسكوا بهواتفهم الذكيه
خاصه ان قطاع الاتصالات لم يتاثر كثيرا
بالزلزال على العكس تماما من شبكات
الكهرباء روان حمزه العربيه
الكاميرات الحراريه
تقنيه تحدد اماكن الاحيان تحت الاوقات
هذه التقنيه يمكنها استشعار نبضات القلب
وتنفس تحت الارض وتحتر كم الالقاب
مبدا عملها يعتمد على استخدام انظمه كشف
ضربات القلب وحراره الجسم وتعمل باستخدام
الاشعه تحت الحمراء تعمل دون تدخل من
العامل البشري المراقب لها استخدامات
العسكريه ومدنيه منها الكشف عن تسرب الغاز
وعمليه البحث والالقاء
[موسيقى]
هذا وما تزال قصه الرضيعه التي ولدت تحت
الانقاض ببلده جنديرس شمال سوريا ولقبت
بعنقاء الزلزال ما تزال تحظى باهتمام وسط
اخبار الموت التي خلفها زلزال المدمر كمال
العربيه رافقت منقذها خليل الذي زارها في
المستشفى استعدادا لنقلها الى بيته خلال
الايام القادمه جديد قصه هذه الرضيعه في
هذه المتابعه للزميل عبد القادر خربوش
[موسيقى]
امل في ان يجد عنقاء الزلزال في صحه جيده
حيث تقضي ايام حياتها الاولى بهذا المشفى
بعفرين رفقه ابنه جرى اول لقاء لهما بها
بعيدا عن الدمار واهوال الزلزال
سعاده تشاركها مع زوجته التي شاءت الاقدار
ان تضع هي الاخرى مولودتها تزامنا مع
الولاده العجيبه لهذه الرضيعه فقرر ان
يمنحها اسما ويتكفل برعايتها الى جانب
ابنتهما طلب مني حموده ابني قال لي سميها
عفراء على اسم خالتي
فسمعتها عفر على اسم امها من ساعتها انه
ابوها راح وامها واخواتها ضلت هي ذكرى
البنت عندي من اهلها صارت وحده من اولادي
يعني ما راح ان شاء الله ما راح اميزها هي
من اولادي يعني وراح تكون اغلى من اولادي
ان شاء الله زاد
لا يكاد خليل يستوعبوا كيف تشبثت عفراء
بالحياه واصطدمار اود بحياه كل افراد
عائلتها والاف عجزت اجسادهم عن مقاومه هول
زلزال لم يبقي ولم يذر فرضنا الله يرحمه
عائلته كانوا ولد عمي يعني واقرب الناس
الي وكان اكثر من اخ لالي هو وكان المقرب
لالي اكثر شيء هو فراحت عيلته كلياتها
زوجته واطفاله واخته فما ظل احدهم غير
البنت ذكرى من عنده فبدي يربيها انا وراح
تظل هاي ذكرى للابد
قصته مع عفراء تعيده الى المكان الذي قطع
فيه حبلها السريه من والدتها ونجح في
اخراجها من تحت هذه الانقاض لتصبح عنوان
امل يحفظ في ذاكره الملايين عن الكارثه
لا يتصور العقل ولا يعني شي فوق الخيال
نصل الساعه اربعه نشتغل جبنا اليات بلشنا
للساعه 2:00 لقينا الطفله هاي تقريبا
وبقدر ما لاقت قصه ولاده الرضيعه تفاعلا
واسعا شكلت بالنسبه لمنقذها خليل منعرجا
حاسما في حياته وسيكون يوم اخراجها من
المشفى ونقلها الى بيته بدايه جديده لفصول
قصه جميله اختصرت مشهد الموت والحياه عبد
القادر خربوش العربيه
هذا وتسبب الزلزال المدمر الذي ضرب جنوب
تركيا وشمال سوريا بخسائر اقتصاديه كبيره
لاسيما في الطرقات والسكك الحديديه
والموانئ والمطارات وسط مخاوف على سلامه
بنيه السدود المائيه حيث تعد المنطقه
المنكوبه منطقه حيويه وتشمل العديد من
الطرق السريعه والسدود والسكك الحديديه
الزلزال قطع العديد من الطرقات السريعه
والفرعيه جنوب البلاد
[موسيقى]
اغلق مطارها اكثر المطارات حيويه في
المنطقه
الاضرار تسببت بتاخر فرق الانقاذ
والمساعدات للمدن المتضرره الزلزال اضر
بخطوط الغاز والنفط وفاقم معاناه
المنكوبين في الشتاء
اتخذت اجراءات لتفريغ السدود من المياه
خوفا من انهيارها
الاحصائيات تشير الى خسائر بمليارات
الدولارات في البنى التحتيه
[موسيقى]
قربه
طلبك
ومع تزايد اعداد ضحايا زلزال في تركيا
وسوريا الى ان ثمت قصصا بطوليه لعالقنا
بين الحطام صمودهم خلق حاله دهشه لدى فرق
الانقاذ حتى انه بات هناك ثمه رابط انساني
بين المنقذين والعالقين
[موسيقى]
هنا يمكنك ان تلمس معجزات تنطق بها الارض
قالها فريق انقاذ الماني يعمل في تركيا
رابط انساني عجيب بين عمال الانقاذ وضحايا
الزلزال
يقضون ساعات طويله يتحدثون الى المنكوبين
يحاولون التخفيف من الامهم حينا واحيانا
كثيره يلقون اليهم باي وسيله ممكنه قد
تعيد اليهم الامل من جديد
زينب كرمان السيده التي خرجت على قيد
الحياه بعد اربع ساعات تحدت خلالها البرده
وانعدام اسباب الحياه بعد يوم من انقاذها
تلقت فرق الانقاذ خبر وفاتها
التزموا الصمت
دعوه يكررها المنقذون للمتجمهرين حول حطام
المباني لعلهم يدركون استغاثه ناج هنا او
هناك
وخلال احدى لحظات الصمت تلك تحديدا في
قهرمان مرعش انتبه عمال الانقاذ لمعجزه
جديده
عائشه الطفله ذات السبعه اعوام خاضت صراعا
طويلا لمده سته ايام وسط امل وخوف اطبق
على المكان لساعات طويله لتولد من جديد
التشبث بالحياه رساله يواصل كتابه سطورها
من هم تحت الانقاض فهذا الرضيع الذي يبلغ
من العمر شهرين خرج حيا وسط ذهول كل من
يتابع المشهد
سيد الحديدي العربيه
[موسيقى]
سنواصل معكم مشاهدينا تغطيتنا لكن نتوقف
الان مع بعض الاخبار الخاصه بملفات اخرى
نبدا من الحرب الاوكرانيه حيث اعلن نائب
وزير الخارجيه الروسي
عن استعداد بلاده التفاوض مع كييف دون
شروط مسبقه مشددا على مراعاه المفاوضات
للاهداف الروسيه المسبق الاعلان عنها
قال ايضا ان قرار المفاوضات مع موسكو لا
يتخذ في كييف بل في واشنطن او بروكسيل
ملتهما للجانب الاوكراني بقطع المفاوضات
رغم بدء روسيا بها فعليا
من جهته قال المستشار برئاسه الاوكرانيه
ميخال بودالياك ان حديث روسيا عن عدم
مغادره اراضي اوكرانيا ضمن تصريحات دوليه
تدلي بها عن محادثات السلام دليل اخر على
ان المحادثات بين الجانبين مستبعده مضيفا
بان اما ان تنتصر اوكرانيا او تظل الحرب
في اوروبا بلا نهايه وستهيمن روسيا بشكل
اجرامي على العالم على حد وصفه
اجرت القوات الاوكرانيه تدريبات العسكريه
على الحدود البيلاروسيه واجريت هذه
المناورات العسكريه بمنطقه تحديدا والتي
تقع شمالي غربي البلاد على حدود بيلاروس
الحليفه لروسيا وتجدر الاشاره الى ان
الجيش الروسي كان اجرى مناورات عسكريه في
بيلاروس قبل اشهر قليله
قال الجيش الاسرائيلي نصاروخا اطلق باتجاه
اسرائيل من قطاع غزه قبل ان تعترضه
دفاعاته الجويه ودوت صافرات الانذار في
المجتمعات الحدوديه او المجتمعات الحدوديه
الاسرائيليه مما دفع الاسرائيليين الى
الهروب الى الملاجئ
اعلنا مجلس سياده السودانيه الاتفاق على
صيغه نهائيه للاعلان السياسي بعد سلسله من
الاجتماعات برئاسه رئيس المجلس السيادي
عبد الفتاح البرهان وبمشاركه الاطراف
الموقعه على الاتفاق الايطالي والاطراف
غير الموقعه عليه وافاد المجلس عن المضي
في الترتيب لاجراءات التوقيع على الاعلان
السياسي بالسرعه المطلوبه
مشاهدينا هذه التغطيه ما تزال مستمره معكم
بعد قليل الساعه جديده اذا نذكر مشاهدينا
اخر حصيله لدينا حوالي
27,500 قتيل جراء هذا الزلزال المدمر الذي
ضرب ولايه كرمان مرعش في جنوب تركيا
واهتزت الارض كذلك في شمال سوريا وادت الى
وقوع خمسه الاف قتيل حتى الان في المناطق
الخاطئه على السيطره النظام والمناطق
الخاضعه للسيطره المعارضه اذا التغطيه
مستمره في الساعه المواليه رشنال معكم في
المتابعه الى اللقاء